[Music]
for twenty years after the assassins
defeated the Templars in London the city
enjoyed a certain peace until the autumn
of terror
in 1888 London is plunged into shadow
and fear by a series of gruesome and
unsolvable murder the brothels of
Whitechapel seem warm and safe by
comparison to its streets where
prostitutes are being mutilated and left
on grotesque display for the world to Oh
God
jacob frye hunts the elusive killer to
bring an end to the terror of Jack the
Ripper get a move on mr. Finch this is
the story of a lifetime mr. Weaver's
Brooke I know you have more of the
rippers letters I told you to stay away
from me stop publishing his letters
you've turned an unknown miss Trent into
a legend and that's exactly what he
wants Jacob thank God I found you
yes sir Ripper he's done it again
Hey
oh we can't no I can't have and Lizzie
not both night one night
Nellie remember what I said now call
Alberta for assassins must die before
you see truth only one more Jack you
should have been to Jacob now I will
hunt you down
I know you're there jack the master of
terror is afraid to show himself is it I
am your shadow Jacob
I will got every last one of them if
that's the quickest YT
[Music]
[Applause]
come on you monster run on the line
check I will catch you
I need to only follow your scent this
scent of a wounded
there is no way good night
[Music]
stop me jack
can I kill me this is not our way this
is my you cannot escape me
scurry back to your hole little mouse
gun somewhere Jacob Jack you're sick
don't you see the irony brother Jack
only you know who the Ripper is but you
can't tell a living soul because it
would destroy you and the assassins we
can fix you fix me I am the solution
[Music]
you
miss fry inspector abberline why exactly
have you had me escorted here my men and
I have been hunting the RIP around the
clock for months now and we've nothing
to show for it it's nothing I can tell
the public what's the Ripper to do with
me
my brother has had me summoned here from
India can't this wait as far as I know
you may be the last assassin in London
what do you mean where's Jacob I wish I
knew your brother is nowhere to be found
even as an elusive shadow is committing
the most hideous crimes this city has
ever seen and you believe this is no
coincidence
the killer is selective and
dispassionate and has left not a single
trace of his passage I've seen such a
talent for assassination and avoiding
detection only once before when I work
with the two of you and that is why your
brother summoned you before he
disappeared you think Jacob is dead I
dare not believe it but if he is you may
be the only person who can stop the
Ripper now follow me
I'll take you to the site where the
Ripper first struck
a journalist always seemed to get the
word first